buen trabajo ahora que sabemos
particionar el espacio en celdas podemos
escribir un programa que dibuje por
nosotros además mi mano está cansada te
va a encantar este programa genera una
cuadrícula uniforme de zonas y traza el
diagrama de voronoi resultante eso
parece un tablero de ajedrez si
cambiamos las líneas de las zonas
obtenemos esto como un panal de abejas
nos estamos acercando a las escamas de
dinosaurios observa que seguimos las
reglas de voronoi del vídeo pasado
cualquier punto en estas líneas es
equidistante a dos o tres de las zonas
muy bien entonces cuántas zonas
necesitamos bien dónde van bueno pues
vamos a ver el paquete de acabados
nuestro dinosaurio es joven y tiene
pocas escamas en sus piernas tal vez con
cinco o siete funcionará hay más escamas
alrededor de las garras pero nos
preocuparemos de eso después lo
importante es que no todas las celdas
tienen la misma forma así es tenemos una
variación muy sutil tanto en el tamaño
de las celdas y su forma no como el
panal perfecto que nuestro programa está
generando
y eso me es útil el poder de los números
aleatorios pero aplicar la dispersión de
una manera que produzca variaciones que
se vean orgánicas es bastante difícil
observa qué pasa cuando dispersamos las
zonas de una manera completamente
aleatoria y después dibujamos las líneas
eso no se ve bien está demasiado
amontonado si es demasiado aleatorio
necesitamos un balance entre la
estructura y la dispersión creo que un
proceso de pozo no funcionará bien aquí
se escucha elegante pero es bastante
sencillo utiliza un nuevo parámetro que
podemos controlar la distancia mínima a
la zona podemos verla como un disco
alrededor de cada punto piensa en ello
como un disco en el que no podemos
agregar más puntos funciona así se
genera una zona aleatoria
luego generamos otra zona fuera del
disco y repetimos esto una y otra vez
hasta que el plano esté lleno
nota que es una manera más suave de
distribuir los puntos ahora está mucho
menos amontonado observa qué pasa cuando
dibujamos la partición nos acercamos más
a la geometría de las escamas del
dinosaurio hermoso bueno en el próximo
ejercicio podrás jugar con estas ideas
cuál fue el uso de la dispersión más
inesperado que has tenido en pixar yo
creo que lo más increíble de la
dispersión aleatoria es que está en
todas partes hasta en materiales que
pueden parecer constantes como la
pintura metálica para automóviles ni
hablemos de la piel humana o de la piel
de dinosaurio hay dispersión aleatoria
en cada material que creamos